LEGISLATION TO DO THAT.
HERE WITH REACTION "OUTNUMBERED"
CO-HOST KAYLEIGH MCENANY AND
CLAY TRAVIS AND MIKE HUCKABEE.
HOW IS SARAH DOING.
SHE IS DOING WELL?
>> SHE IS.
CANCER FREE.
THEY GOT EVERYTHING IN SURGERY.
WE APPRECIATE THE PRAYERS AND
LOVE OF SO MANY PEOPLE.
IT'S OVER AND A RECOVERY POINT
FROM HERE.
THANKS FOR ASKING.
A LOT OF PEOPLE'S PRAYERS WERE
ANSWERED.
>> Sean: I PREDICT SHE WILL GO
DOWN IN ARKANSAS HISTORY AS THE
BEST GOVERNOR EVER IN THAT
STATE?
>> I WOULD BE THE HAPPIEST GUY
IN AMERICA.
SEAN, WE WILL HAVE A MUCH BETTER
TENURE AS GOVERNOR OF ARKANSASES
THAT JOE BIDEN IS HAVING.
THAT INTERVIEW, ALL I CAN THINK
OF RUNNING THROUGH THE WHITE
HOUSE SAYING CLEAN UP IN AISLE
4!
JOE HAS BEEN ON TV -- WE HAVE
A MESS TO DEAL WITH.
>> Sean: KAYLEIGH MCENANY,
INFLATION, HE SAID IT DID NOT
SPIKE.
INHERITED 1.4% FROM DONALD TRUMP
AND NOW 8.35%.
A 40 YEAR HIGH.
CLAIMED THE PANDEMIC IS OVER.
WATCH ME.
WE HAVE BEEN WATCHING HIM.
NOT THE FIRST TIME BUT THE
SECOND TIME HE SCREWED UP THE
TAIWAN ANSWER.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
>> YES, IT'S TERRIFYING.
THESE GAFFES ESPECIALLY MADE IN
THE FOREIGN POLICY CONTEXT.
IT'S ONE THING WHEN THE EASTER
BUNNY HOPS OVER TO STOP HIM FROM
TALKING.
A SMART MOVE BY SOMEONE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE PRESS OFFICE.
I WOULD HAVE DONE THE SAME
THING.
BUT IT'S ANOTHER THING WHEN IT'S
MESSING UP THE DOCTRINE ABOUT
TAIWAN WHICH HE DID TWICE.
A WHITE HOUSE STAFFER HAS TO
CORRECT IT.
IT'S ANOTHER THING WHEN HE IS
GIVING HIS SECOND EVER PRESS
BRIEFING AND HE MAKES THIS
REMARK INTO A MINOR INCURSION
BEING ONE THING AND JEN PSAKI
HAS TO PUT A STATEMENT
IMMEDIATELY WHEN HE IS DONE
WHICH MEANS IN REAL TIME SHE WAS
DRAFTING THAT STATEMENT IN HER
OFFICE AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WAS SPEAKING.
HE SUGGESTEDED REGIME CHANGE IN
RUSSIA FROM VLADIMIR PUTIN.
-- IT'S ONE THING WHEN THEY ARE
SMALL GAFFES BUT IN A GLOBAL
CONTEXT IT'S TROUBLING.
>> Sean: I WANT TO TALK ABOUT,
CLAY, HE SAID INFLATION HASN'T
SPIKED.
THE AVERAGE COUPLE IN AMERICA
BECAUSE OF HIS INCOME AND ENERGY
POLICIES, A COUPLE IS PAYING
$6800 MORE THAN UNDER DONALD
TRUMP.
TWO-THIRDS OF THE COUNTRY IS
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
DEMOCRATS WERE UPSET WITH BUSH
HAD NOT BEEN TO A STORE IN AGES
AND DIDN'T KNOW THE PRICE OF
MILK.
THIS GUY DOESN'T KNOW THE PRICE
EVER HIS INFLATION POLICIES?
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
13.5% GROCERY BILL INCREASE.
1.4% WHEN HE STARTED AND 8.3%
NOW.
NOT ONLY THAT PRICES ARE UP, BUT
REAL WAGES ARE DOWN.
IF YOU ARE WORKING IN THIS BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION YOU GOT A MAJOR
TAX INCREASE EVERY MONTH.
WHAT YOU ARE BRINGING IS HOME IS
LESS THAN WHAT THE GOODS YOU
PURCHASE COST.
THE MORE YOU LIVE PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK -- GAS PRICES WERE
GOING UP.
I PULLED UP TO THE GAS PUMP AND
SOMEBODY RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME
HAD PULLED UP AND ONLY BOUGHT
ONE GALLON OF GAS WHEN THE GAS
IN TENNESSEE WAS APPROACHING
$5.55.
SOMEBODY TRYING TO GET THEIR KID
TO SCHOOL -- THIS IS A BRUTAL
UNIVERSE THAT JOE BIDEN CREATED.
I WILL SAY YOU LOOK AT THAT "60
MINUTES" INTERVIEW, THE FIRST
ONE IN 7 MONTHS, DEMOCRATS LOSE
EVERY TIME BIDEN OPENS HIS
MOUTH.
THEY HAD THE TUESDAY EVENT TO
CELEBRATE THE INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT AS THE STOCK
MARKET DROPPED.
BIDEN IS THE WORST SALES MEN FOR
A DISASTROUS POLICY.
I HOPE HE KEEPS TALKING OVER THE
NEXT 50 DAYS.
OF TIME HE TALKS THEY LOSE
VOTERS.
>> Sean: I AGREE.
THIS MAGA REPUBLICAN ATTACK IS
BACK FIRING TOO.
GOVERNOR HUCKABEE, THERE ARE A
LOT OF IN POLITICS RUNNING THIS
YEAR.
WHAT ADVICE DO YOU GIVE THEM.
DONALD TRUMP AND JANUARY 6TH AND
THEN TALK ABOUT ABORTION AND
REPUBLICANS ARE RACISTS.
WHAT DO YOU ADVISE ANY
POLITICIAN AS A CONSERVATIVE
REPUBLICAN HOW TO WIN THEIR RACE
IN 50 DAYS?
>> KEEP IT SIMPLE.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT GASOLINE,
GROCERIES AND GOD.
REMIND THEM HOW MUCH THEY ARE
PAYING FOR GAS SINCE JOE BIDEN
TOOK OFFICE AND IN GROCERIES AND
HOW HARD IT IS TO PUT THE FOOD
ON THE TABLE.
REMIND THEM THAT JOE BIDEN, HIS
GOD IS GOVERNMENT AND THE FAR
LEFT THEIR GOD IS THE CREATED
RATHER THAN THE CREATOR.
SOME OF US BELIEVE THAT LIFE IS
PRECIOUS.
DON'T APOLOGIZE ON THE LEFT
ISSUE.
TAKE IT BACK TO THE DEMOCRATS
AND SAY YOU MAY THINK THAT WE
PROTECT LIFE TOO MUCH.
TELL US AT WHAT POINT IS IT OKAY
TO TAKE THE BABY'S LIFE?
KEEP IT SIMPLE.
GAS, GROCERIES AND GOD.
>> Sean: AND KAYLEIGH MCENANY, I
WOULD AD LAW AND ORDER AND
SAFETY AND SECURE TO PURSUE
HAPPINESS.
AND PARENTAL RIGHTS IN
EDUCATION.
GLENN YOUNGKIN SHOWED THAT WAS
A MAJOR ISSUE FOR PARENTS IN
VIRGINIA.
>> BINGO.
GOVERNOR YOUNGKIN AMONG THOSE
WHO CONSIDERED CRITICAL RACE
THEORY A BIG ISSUE.
72% OF THEM VOTED FOR GOVERNOR
YOUNGKIN.
IT WAS THE REPUBLICAN YOUNGKIN
WINNING ON EDUCATION WHICH
DOESN'T HAPPEN FOR A PARTY BUT
HAPPENING NOW.
AS A MOM, I HEAR THIS ALL THE
TIME.
WHETHER I AM IN NEW YORK,
FLORIDA, BLUE OR RED, PEOPLE DO
NOT WANT THEIR CHILDREN BEING
TAUGHT YOU MAY BE ANOTHER GENDER
BUT HIDE IT FROM MOM UNTIL WE
FIND OUT A SUICIDE IN
A BATHROOM.
MAMMA BEAR IS COMING TO VOTE.
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
GOVERNOR O